c'est un président élu qui est venu se
recueillir à l'aéroport de kiev ce matin
devant les photos d'un équipage perdu le
silence avant de briser le siège pour la
première fois depuis que l'avion s'est
écrasé près de téhéran
un message télévisé des plus officielles
dans lequel volodymyr hélène ce qui
confirme qu'une équipe d'experts
ukrainienne en iran en quête de la
vérité
pire encore temps de la patience la
retenue et la sagesse imposer le
président puis la nouvelle est tombée
l'avion a été abattu par un missile
iranien titre le magazine newsweek
des médias américains et cite des
sources du pentagone et du renseignement
irakiens qui affirme que c'est le
système de défense anti-aérien de l'iran
qui a frappé le boeing fort probablement
par erreur dans les circonstances de
tension dans la région
de toute évidence le président américain
dans l'autre un pet est au courant il a
voulu prendre ses distances de cette
erreur monumentale s'il en est une
et si elle se confirme mais les
américains semblent en être convaincu
selon eux deux tirs ont été détectés sur
leur radar juste avant l'écrasement
l'avion aurait été frappé de plein fouet
par un missile de type tort comme le
montre cette vidéo captée là où
l'appareil a cessé de transmettre son
signal et c'est une thèse solide selon
le gouvernement de justin trudeau
nous avons des renseignements provenant
de différentes sources notamment de nos
services de renseignement et ceux de
ceux de nos alliés
ces renseignements indiquent que l'avion
aurait été abattu par un missile surface
air et règne un développement perturbant
qui réitère l'importance de convaincre
téhéran de laisser du personnel canadien
entrés en iran d'abord pour identifier
les victimes
et surtout pour participer activement à
l' enquête sur le terrain
et s'assurer qu'elles soient
transparentes et crédibles dit justin
trudeau pour l'instant errants indiqué
qu'il allait garder les boîtes noires
chez eux mais ils ont indiqué aux prises
d'antenne ce qui est de l'ukraine que
les enquêteurs ukrainiens au moins
allait avoir accès à ces boîtes noires
ces experts ukrainiens qui sont les
seuls en iran montrent entre autres la
tâche de fouiller les débris à la
recherche de preuves comme des éclats
d'obus
ils sont les mêmes qui avaient mené leur
enquête sur le vol images 17 de la
malaysian airline abattu au dessus du
donbass en 2014 par un missile russe
l'histoire se répète cruellement pour
des passagers qui n'y étaient pour rien
et des familles qui se morfondent et
devront braver les tensions
diplomatiques
encore une fois pour avoir des réponses
ici tamar alter escaut radio canada